on donne mon jour alors les derniers
chiffres publiés au niveau national sont
encourageants mais la situation semble
varier fortement selon les régions où
les autorités ont souligné à de
nombreuses reprises les différentes
régions de russie ne sont pas atteintes
de la même façon par cette pandémie
parmi les régions les plus touchées il y
a donc le daghestan cette république
russe située dans le nord du caucase où
de nombreux personnels de santé
ils sont morts de pneumonie ou des
suites du cours d'un virus d'après le
ministre de la santé de la région alors
plusieurs facteurs en sont la cause
il ya le manque de respect des règles de
confinement ou encore l'auto médication
et le recours trop tardif aux soins
médicaux et vladimir poutine s'en est
inquiété lors de sa dernière
visioconférence écouter déguster la
situation daguestan est difficile de
plus en plus de cas d'infection et de
complications graves sont identifiés et
ces derniers jours le système de santé
de la région a été mise à rude épreuve
malgré les efforts des goûts et des
médecins et des infirmiers le nombre de
tragédies a augmenté y compris au sein
du personnel soignant
en outre on dit que les soins médicaux
nécessaires ne sont pas toujours et
partout disponibles en temps voulu et
dans leur intégralité
lou doillon et l'atonie après 10 min
vise en effet des infrastructures
médicales sur place ne sont pas celles
de la capitale même si la construction
dans cette région de trois nouveaux
complexes médicaux a été annoncée par
exemple la russie à cette approche on a
déjà dit de tester un maximum de monde
plus de 7 millions et demi de tests ont
déjà été réalisés mais au daguestan
le nombre de tests menés est deux fois
moindre que prévu faute de laboratoire
pour pouvoir analyser les échantillons
en conséquence le personnel médical sur
place traite tous les patients de la
même manière qu'il s'agisse de cas
confirmés ou non en attendant reste donc
la prévention pour tenter d'enrayer la
propagation du virus
même la superstar de la mma kraby no
mago madoff est monté au créneau pour
appeler ses compatriotes à respecter le
confinement dans le reste du pays
la lente décrue se confirme et pour la
première fois depuis le début de cette
crise il ya davantage de guérison
enregis
que de nouveaux cas ces dernières 24
heures mais comme on vient de le voir la
situation est loin d'être homogène
partout
antoine merci beaucoup pour tout ces
précisions